Just Take Your Eye Off the ball for one  second which Magnus has done several  times then it can affect you for example  if we remember magnus's lost to go cash  he was winning but maybe because he  wasn't feeling great he was rushing  things took his eye off the ball one  blunder and that was it turn around  so okay we expect Magnus to be slightly  more recovered and he starts with the  Sicilian Defense  I've been with a much more  prepared this is more mainstream yeah  more mainstream uh it's very kind of you  you found good to say provocative for  magnus's previous opening choices  against aragosi it was just I don't know  it's playing bad